Looking at this plot, we can see that we have
some funky outliers in here. And down here is the bulk
of our data. To determine good x and y limits for
our axis, we can look at 95th percentile, using the Quantile
command. This will let us see the ninety-fifth percentile of
www_likes_received. And the ninety-fifth percentile
of likes received. And hopefully, we
should get rid of some of these points. To do that,
I'll use the x lim layer and the y lim layer.
We'll pass zero as the lower bound for x lim, and
for the upper limit, we'll use the ninety-fifth percent quantile for
the ww likes received. Similarly, for likes received, we'll use the
same sort of syntax and just replace the variable. Zero will
be our lower bound, and the ninety fifth percentile for likes
received will be our upper bound. When I run this code,
we're in effect zooming in on that lower portion of the
graph that we had over here. The slope of the line of
best fit through these points is the correlation. And, we can
even add to the plot by using some code. We do
that by adding a smoother, and setting the method to a
linear model or lm. Notice too that I also colored it
red so that we could see it through the black points.
Let's quantify this relationship with a number. So what's the correlation
between our two variables? I don't want you to have to
subset the data, so just include all the data points and
then round your answer to three decimal places.